[MUSIC PLAYING]
LYLA FUJIWARA: Navigating
around an app, by which I
mean moving from one
screen to another,
is an absolutely fundamental
part of Android development.
Historically you'd do this
using intents or fragment
transactions, which in simple
cases, like clicking a button,
was easy enough.
But what if you wanted to do
something just slightly more
complex?
For example, hooking up a common
pattern like bottom navigation.
You'd need to make sure that
not only your Bottom Navigation
view actually navigates
but also that it
highlights the correct button.
Oh, and also that it handles
the backstack in a uniform way
so that users don't end up
getting lost or confused.
Cases like this are where
the new navigation component
shines.
The navigation component
is a collection
of libraries, a
plug-in, and tooling
that simplifies
Android navigation.
Beyond making the setup for
common patterns like Bottom
Navigation easier, the
component handles the backstack,
fragment transactions,
argument passing,
navigation-based animations,
and deep linking.
Importantly, it gathers up all
of this navigation information
and puts it in one visualized
location of your app,
the Navigation graph.
The navigation
component works out
of the box with
fragments and activities.
You can also extend the library
to work with other screen
implementations, like
your custom views.
Let's look at some examples
of the navigation components
in action, with a single
activity swapping out
multiple fragments.
If you're wondering
why you might consider
a single-activity model, check
out Ian Link's excellent talk,
which I've linked in the notes.
OK.
So one way to think about
the navigation component
is that there are three
major parts working together
in harmony.
These are the Navigation
graph, the NavHostFragment,
and the NavController.
The Navigation graph
is a new resource type.
It's an XML file that contains
and centralizes information
related to navigation.
Now this information
can be visualized
in the new Navigation editor
that is available in Android
Studio 3.3.
It's a graphical
editor to create this,
well, Navigation graph.
Each of these screens
are called destinations,
or places that you
can navigate to.
In this example,
they're all fragments.
Now these arrows here
are called actions
and they represent
the different paths
that a user could
take through your app.
If you click on
one of the actions,
you can see a whole bunch
of embedded information,
including data passed
between destinations,
transition animations, backstack
manipulation, and so on.
Clicking on a destination, you
can see things like deep link
URLs and launch options.
This is all part of
the XML of the graph.
OK, so next, we have
the NavHostFragment.
This is a fragment widget that
you'll add to your layout,
assuming that you're
doing fragment navigation.
It's basically a window
that swaps in and out
different fragment
destinations that are included
in your Navigation graph.
The final piece of the
puzzle is the NavController.
Each NavHostFragment
has a NavController
that you'll use in your
Kotlin or Java code.
And this is what actually
instructs the navigation
to occur.
So if I write some
code like this,
the NavController will then
perform this navigation action
based off of all of
that information that
was in the Navigation graph,
and it will ultimately
swap out which fragment is
shown in the NavHost fragment.
Now here I'm using
the action's XML ID
to specify which of those
action arrows to follow,
but an even better way to do
this is using the navigation
component's SafeArgs plug-in.
The SafeArgs plug-in
generates code
to allow you to use
type-safe navigation
and argument passing.
First, you'll add the
Gradle plug-in to your code.
This will generate classes based
off of your Navigation graph.
It'll make these
Direction classes
for any destination
that has actions
and it will make Args
classes for any destination
with arguments.
If you take your original
navigation statement,
you can swap in these
generated classes
and you'll get something
that looks like this.
Instead of referring to
an action by its XML ID,
you're making sure that
you have an action that's
actually associated
with your destination.
You can also set
arguments of the action.
Pass in the wrong type and
the code won't compile.
Getting the arguments you
passed through is easy.
Simply use the
GeneratedArgs class
and you have type-safe
access to only
the correctly-named arguments.
No need to worry about the
key value pairs of yesteryear.
So that was simple navigation.
Let's talk about setting
up that bottom nav.
The navigation
component includes
an additional navigation
UI library in Java and KTX
extensions for Kotlin,
that have support
for options menus, bottom
navigation, navigation
view, and navigation drawer.
It also works with
action bar, toolbar,
and collapsing toolbar.
For our bottom nav,
you'd cut the bottom nav
to your XML as normal.
You'd also create
an XML menu with IDs
that match the XML IDs
of your destinations
and your Navigation graph that
you want the bottom navigation
to go to.
Then you'd use navigation
UI to wire up the rest.
In Kotlin, that's done with
this handy extension function.
This one line of code
has NavController
handle the actual
navigation, making
sure to follow material
design best practices as far
as backstack management goes.
On top of that, it
handles highlighting
the correct bottom buttons.
Now we have only
explored a few parts
of the navigation component.
For a deeper trek
into navigation,
check out the code lab
and the documentation,
all linked below.
Happy coding and
happy navigating.